have you done stand-up comedy before you
announced you want to go into stand-up
comedy i had a comic actually bring me
to like something secretive unannounced
just to see what the crowd was what's
the comic um i'm actually not gonna say
that because he does perform every night
but i realized so the fact that he
performs every night yeah it's it's uh
it's good to not mention his name
did he say i'm going to bring you the
club but don't tell him i brought you
yeah i'm not really like
in contact with everything i used to be
in contact with before i try trauma
center so i'm just kind of respecting
like where i'm at with like my relations
but i'm not asking you having a
relationship with him or her
we're going into relations so anyways i
went to this kind of thing
yes i was going into this and i did it
for five minutes he wanted to see the
reaction and basically he recorded it
and he saw that it was like women
standing up cheering me on like men
laughing so i was like even if i fail at
comedy i could be really good at ted
talks so either way
it's either stand-up comedy or a ted
talk let's get it
so the men were laughing the men were
laughing probably thank you
and you don't want to tell us who the
comic was i don't feel comfortable with
it at this time how does he get in
trouble i'm not saying you have a
relationship with this person this is
how you got to the comedy club i'm not i
don't want to even say if you have a
relationship yeah i really appreciated
though like watching so many comedic
podcasts going to the laugh factory
going to the comedy store
and i got to watch a lot maybe i fell
asleep maybe i had a good time but i
learned a lot from watching it over the
years so i'm ready
that's how i feel so this is like a new
you know writing's tedious but i love
writing too no but maybe you fell asleep
and maybe you didn't yeah i don't
understand what you're talking about
you fell asleep in a comedy club i did
where what
well you mentioned the comic that was on
no
no no not that you were with some some
people think people are great and i'm
not going to diminish like that but i
learned a lot from watching a lot of
people at the comedy how do you learn
from sleeping like if you're sleeping at
the comedy i learned that
i could not
like that genre of comedy
what kind of i'm sleeping what is the
genre what is the genre of comedy that
puts you to sleep um it was a father
talking about his experiences as a dad
and i got really tired from that yeah
you know i i'm doing this podcast with
my daughter as a dad yeah
but you're entertaining dad i did not
know that you were his daughter yeah
this is my daughter and i love that
families are together
hence my daughter
i love you guys i love you guys i know
but if i talk too much about it i want
you to stay awake because we find that
on you i'm like focused i'm woke so and
now that the next place you're going is
stand-up comedy what is your act about
oh my act i don't know if i have to act
but it's definitely about motherhood
being a single parent whether it's about
my sexuality which is a very big topic
of conversation in the news whether it's
like people wanting to bathe in my poop
which was outrageous and crazy for me
were you not selling your poop though i
was not you never sold it
ever
people offer me five thousand dollars
for stinky poop that comes out of me and
i'm just like i don't even think that
could go in the mail wait wait i saw a
video of you yeah showing that you look
how good my comedy was and people
believe that oh my gosh they ran with it
they were like i want to bathe in it
wait a minute that's not real that's not
real i thought it was real was it a
picture was it a picture i'm doing my
job so well so you didn't because we had
a woman on here that was selling her
farts yes and i actually have met her
and she did like online platform stuff
too and i think i was kind of like what
she was serious yeah she is serious um
but i get kind of like inspired with
like people being able to like sell
farts and i was like oh i'll sell farts
oh my god but then i have like these
little jars and i was like maybe i
should put poop in it and then if i
asked about it it really blew up
it really blew up but i've never
gotten the chance to do that i don't
think i think that's an opportunity you
consider that i think it's a comedic
funny thing to talk about but you've
never sold one piece of [ __ ] no i'm
sorry but i saw on your website that
you're telling you're going to sell poop
slime yes well my team was like you know
what pharah let's like
make some fun with this so poop slime i
was like my daughter loved poop slime
and she still makes slime so i was like
okay poop slime bathe in that and that's
much safer and doesn't slime that's not
but and you don't use your own poop but
you don't make it you don't have to eat
anything to manufacture that have fun
with it
make comedy out of it yeah that is funny
but that's great you say you know what
up until this moment until you answered
i swear to you i had no idea that that
was a joke i didn't either
and i freaked out what i do and i think
most people that's a you know what
that's a headline it wasn't
no [ __ ] there was no she never pooped
she never sold her poop
sometimes with comedy though it's scary
because they take what you're saying
really seriously yes and i think like
that's why i was like whatever since
people like blow things up i'm gonna
just like really laugh with people
[Music]
you